players who want to succeed in League of
Legends have to be strong
to being the Champions but how many
times could you fail before you stopped
believing that victory was possible
for your regrets piled up and buried
your hopes of ever finding a way but it
doesn't even matter there's nothing to
death do SK Telecom it's the reverse
sweep bringing it back in they win three
to two and if you somehow kept going
could you turn your last chance into the
greatest story that worlds has ever seen
[Applause]
world champion
foreign
[Music]
but before we get into the highs and
lows of deft I want to thank our sponsor
Opera GX the ultimate browser for gamers
now I'm a guy that likes to min max my
life I like to sleep on top of my duvet
so I don't have to make my bed in the
morning I'll make all my coffees for the
week at the very same time I'll even get
all my friends in the same Discord call
so I don't have to catch up with them
all individually
[Music]
so being the multitasking madman that I
am I need a browser that can keep up
with me and that my friend is where
Opera GX comes in it has twitch and
Discord integration so I can chat with
my friends or watch streams in my
browser I don't have to juggle between
both applications anymore now before
Opera GX if I found something cool
online I wanted to save it for later I'd
have to use a website or a different
program now I just use pin boards in
Opera GX it saves so much time just
having it all in one place and for the
ultimate Min maxing I use the built-in
VPN that's right this browser has it
built in so you don't have to flick
between your browser and another program
which genuinely feels like a life hack
I've sat down and calculated that Opera
GX could save me about a hundred hours
of my time a year now of course a lot of
that I'll probably put straight back
into League of Legends but here's the
point you should try Opera GX the
browser built specifically for gamers
you can use the link in our description
box below to download it for free and
find out just how much time you can save
the world of competitive League of
Legends barely existed in 2012. Korea's
Champions League had only just started
but that didn't stop Kim Deft Q from
imagining a future in it while Regional
leagues and seasonal schedules were
coming together Deft was a high school
kid trying to work his way up the ladder
but someone else at his school had the
same goal Faker was already a dominant
solo Q player and he hadn't even heard
of deft
and after graduating both Faker and Deft
went pro in 2013 but while their latter
results were fairly close their rookie
seasons were miles apart and there's a
surrender surrender at 20
and that is it Baker
absolutely owning MVP blue death Team
MVP blue were hard stuck in groups in
both spring and summer while Faker LED
SKT t1k to a world championship Victory
this could be a 20-minute game for SK
Telecom they will be the season three
world champions here at the Staples
Center but the next year Samsung
purchased MVP's roster and with a more
stable team environment behind him def
finally got the chance to prove himself
and that type of Team coordination puts
the final nail on the coffin to najin
White shield and it is that type of play
that runs out so blue to their long
journey to being the champions in
Champions League
Deft and Samsung blue dominated in 2014
and thanks to his incredible team
fighting he made a name for himself as
one of the best ad carry trees in the
world best of all Samsung blue made
worlds while fakers SKT t1k was nowhere
to be found and death popped off oh no
no no they are completely gone out of
position facility leaps away is the
rocket jumping off no deflanches are
locking down the teleport comes in but I
think that's just gonna be another
victim for Samsung blue Ackerman joins
the fight in they go slides off through
triple kill for death thank you very
much you can OMG a caught out of
position the wave counties onto WhatsApp
the intervention isn't enough to save
his life the Rocket Jump away but he
will get burnt down but going against
Gods out as well it's a double bill for
death it's gonna take a bit of a miracle
here for Cloud9 and Nexus turret will be
finished off the focus on to the Nexus
and Samsung blue with an amazing ending
here in game number four they made a
deep run to semi-finals but lost that
series to their sister team and eventual
Champions Samsung white still deaf got
so close to the game's biggest prize in
his second year and he did it while
absolutely styling on his opponents
which was probably why Daft was an
obvious Prospect for recruitment when
Chinese teams started looking for Korean
talent in the off-season but leaving
Korea wasn't an easy decision China
still hadn't won a World's title and
Beyond the language barrier death was
just 17 moving to another country wasn't
going to be easy but he had a goals
foreign
ER than ever to show just how good he
was and alongside his talented support
Mako he'd lit up the opposition double
trendy for us but make always wants to
go in he's gone in there does have the
Timbers now but cool just evaporates him
and now go get
upon Pawn don't spot the audio on
himself because they live in the back
doing good damage and death gonna start
the cleanup get one gonna get two can he
make it a triple goes in there's three
there's four no Koro he's still the
panther kill death has to settle for a
Quadra for support like clear up going
back in Akon around the Cyber death
finally makes it in Godby getting tanked
up as well clearly have actually died
this Pawn goes back into mako's not here
in depth now peeled away but Coro does
so much work in the back line but it
might not be enough here Point meet the
final kill to everybody
gets the kill that's two kills death
goes back in versus aggressive Pawn
needs to kite away death what the hell
gets a dribble kill gets the quarter
gets the better kill what on Earth is
going on one turret down energy are
training down these turrets can they
take out the game pie of back tbq's back
as well if it's going in with energy
they're committing they want to go for
that Nexus they take it out the what's
and future kings authentic into the
throne EDG your 2015 lb Well Spring
winners after a season packed with
highlights def didn't just grab a
domestic title hidg earned their shot to
compete at the inaugural MSI and EDG did
not disappoint making it all the way to
the finals only one thing stood in
death's way Faker faker's LeBlanc one of
the best yes sir
he locks it in
for game five
since beating death with LeBlanc all the
way in their first ever Showdown Faker
had gone on an unprecedented 11-game
undefeated streak with the champion but
Deft and EDG were ready when Faker
pulled out all the stops in a decisive
game five here's the last engage EDG
doesn't even see the turrets eyes on SKT
SK Telecom T1 are white the Nexus
turrets are going down lpl's Edward
gaming are their 2015 mid-season
Invitational champions
Deft did it he took down what many
considered to be the best team in the
world he exercised his demons from the
trouncing faker gave him back in 2013
and he proved his decision to leave
South Korea was the right one but worlds
were still ahead of him unfortunately
after a slower summer season adg
disappointed at Worlds they made it to
the quarter-finals but def's World
Championship dreams were crushed by an
unlikely opponent the road to the Nexus
and from magic will advance to the
semi-finals the only team to do that
three times in the world championships
then in 2016 adg went undefeated in
summer but again Deft and his team
stumbled in world's quarter-finals rocks
hoping to get revenge
Revenge gun form hoping to win a world
championship and the lost stung even
more as he watched his greatest rival
lift the Summoners cup for a third time
so in 2017 death made another momentous
Choice he joined KT and he came home but
returning to Korea was the easy part
breaking through after his return was
harder and Faker was still in his way
but SK Telecom in the meantime they've
done it less than 30 minutes on the
clock they take down the Nexus they take
down KT rolls then they put another
championship title and SKT T1 will be
going to MSI oh wanna Lonesome but it
doesn't even matter there's nothing that
depth can do SK Telecom in the
semi-final they're going on the play
against Longshore a week from today it's
the reverse sweep bringing it back in
they went three to two for the first
time in three years death Miss worlds
entirely well Faker made it all the way
to the finals 2018 looked like it was
going to be a repeat until Katie hit
their stride mid-year but this time
instead of Faker a new group of
youngsters stood in death's way
it's guaranteed and if they waste his
time maybe they win anyway that was a
face check and you can managed to get it
done it just about dies but the grand
entrance gets himself out Piper finds it
away oh the death I'll play SKT haven't
lost a member the last Nexus turret and
the storyline for four is completed
they're already off their speed in in
one of the greatest best of Five series
of all time Deft and Katie rolster made
it back to Worlds as lck Champions and
Korea's first seed but once again the
door was slammed on death in the
quarter-finals
not been done since 2014. they will
eliminate the Korean first seed and they
will move on to the semi-final IG did
what Daft had always dreamed of they
built a roster strong enough to not just
compete at Worlds but win the whole
thing and death's dreams of Victory were
slipping further and further out of his
reach he managed to turn out impressive
individual performances over the next
few years but fell short internationally
he missed worlds altogether in 2019 and
struggled to keep up with the rising
stars of Korea's Next Generation this
Nexus very soon to go down and down one
looking absolutely Unstoppable in this
first quarter final and it wasn't just
new names and faces holding Deft back in
2021 he got off to a slow start with his
new team hanwa life but rebounded again
earning another trip to Worlds I'll need
to come face to face with an old rival
it doesn't even matter though it's
heroic but it's not going to matter T1
will 3-0 harm alive Esports they wanted
to do this in the world's Gauntlet
thankfully they got a second try and
damn second time was the charm Daft was
coming up on a decade of professional
play and it seemed like his best years
were long behind him and now with a
young DRX team around him for the 2022
season he questioned whether the old
death was really what his team needed
the team definitely needed something as
they limped through a middling season
that impressed no one so this team has
like good names on it you know piosic
Deft Barrel but I feel like no this this
this ain't it this team ain't it I feel
like death might be cashing cashing out
a bit here or I hope so I think this is
like 56th Place senior death had been
here before with the regional Gauntlet
his only chance of making worlds but no
one was counting on him to succeed this
time can Durex go all the way like depth
did on Han Wildlife Esports just one
year ago yeah I mean there's still The
Underdogs coming into this one that's
not a uh a secret obviously I think that
it wasn't upset yesterday can they do it
again though but DRX surprised Everyone
by winning two back-to-back five game
slogs to earn a spot of Worlds this was
the one t before saying there's no
chances they'll wait the Eric beats KT
live sandbox is their final opponent
here they bring it back in game five the
kill score in set game five
23-3 more than 15
000 gold ahead and TRX they are going
towards Jeff is going again barrels
going again two on Subs in the
Difference Maker for this team even then
though they were Korea's last seed
forced to start in Planes a team had
never run the bracket from Planes all
the way to finals death's hopes looked
as dim as ever still DRX started strong
but he's still fighting five members off
the side of the RX nothing that they can
do TRX and death dominate
RNG they were the only team to go
undefeated in planes and they kept up
that momentum
knows Godlike and DRX go in for more
that's four down Katie's the only one
alive but the ever Frost seals his fate
and Dr X will earn their place in the
quarterfinals DRX played close games in
the group stage matches but they topped
the group showing they deserved their
spot in the brackets but to truly prove
himself Daft would have to beat his
quarter-finals curse and the reigning
world champions adg weren't going to
make it easy three alive can they kill
time JJ gets Low by Bruce still hitting
he's got the guardian angel
playing for Barrett it's secured but
death kills he's got it he kills turret
number two and the Nexus is in his eyes
and he's gonna get oh yeah
he cannot get the stuff
[Applause]
oh my God
foreign
[Applause]
it was a heartbreaking way to lose game
two and yet down two games in
quarterfinals def decided to pin his
tournament hopes on something he had
barely ever played on stage so the wild
thing is Deft has two recorded games on
Draven across his career he has many
Vladimir games he has Draven games
across his career zero and two on the
champion digs it out here and says this
is the right call for it with strong
team fighting and objective control DRX
took game three with death Draven
leading the charge cannot find his man
just get me back drop but they're on the
Nexus death finally gets the shot and
the RX didn't let up they had fought too
hard to go quietly attacked Again by
King and flandre second place here as
well bailout not gonna be enough they've
killed off now they've killed off Mako
they'll kill off Viper they'll kill off
everybody and this Nexus is not gonna be
saved we're gonna take game four and DRX
bring us to Silver Screen
942 days ago Jeff what a wild
quarterfinal and and today
thanks to second he does it again Daft
was back in World semi-finals it took
him eight long years but he got there he
just had to defeat his former teammates
and the reigning world champions in a
reverse
sweeps
had matched his career best but he need
to defeat gen G to go any further Genji
was Korea's first seed the roster
boasted a few of death's former
teammates and most importantly they
hadn't lost a game to DRX all year Genji
have kind of dominated DRX all year but
surely it's not that bad right but in
many ways this wasn't the same team
they'd swept back home
going down
the sister team in Samsung life but
today in the face
Invincible odds he stands tall the Last
Dance goes on
[Applause]
the stage here's one more page
he has one chance to kill the king and
today he did not miss and so Deft was
through to finals in a year where no one
expected much he had achieved more than
ever before but there was one more
obstacle in his way the one that had
always been there before Daft had gone
to China before he had put on the colors
of a shable before he even went pro
Faker despite starting at the same High
School the two men took very different
paths and those journeys led both of
them here to the world's finals it all
came down to one best of five Faker
hoped to add a fourth world championship
to his trophy cabinet meanwhile Daft was
trying to climb to a summit he had never
even seen before but that he knew deep
down he could conquer the stage was set
the storylines well traced all that was
left was to write history check up grabs
a third and third now going to find
Faker here in the bottom Lane Canyon and
death do the work and that's one in
death pocket they're going in they found
a lot of damage with a roll for the kill
just yet now govern you she's gonna be
popped and Barrel he's not traded back
Zach had taken some damage Faker trying
to go in and find his way through the
smoke now he's gonna run he's trying to
get out but twisted and fans will find
him and TRX will win across the rim he's
trying to run away but second bio should
go still chasing touchdown a Bullet to
the Head and death pulled the trigger
he's trying to send him away
they're going for the next test can they
do it in time King comes back Eleanor
taking the ready but what can he do two
three no damage just yet
is
hold carrier wants to hit the wave
is dead they have been doubted they have
been discounted they have been dismissed
but Dr
are you a t22 world champion Daft didn't
just win Worlds he made the miracle run
with his team all the way from Planes
and he beat Faker to do it the mentality
of
[Applause]
[Music]
Deft and Faker shared more than a high
school or a country even though their
paths diverged they both lived by the
same code when his longest shot ever to
win world came his way Deft had to
believe it was possible it was possible
for a man who spent nine Seasons chasing
the Summoners cup to change his fate it
was possible for a team coming into
Worlds as a fourth seed with a losing
record to win it all and even if it
seemed impossible at first death made
all of us believe it too
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification Bell for Unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else hit us up on our Twitter
Instagram Facebook and tick tock